So we've known for a long time now that there
are more than 15 or so women who credibly
have accused Donald [inaudible] that
Trump of sexual assault or sexual harassment
or Mala station, sometimes even rising to
the threshold of rape.
In fact, uh, when we learned that this new
book was coming out, all the presidents, women,
Donald Trump and the making of a predator,
it was previewed to us that there were about
25 more women who detailed their maltreatment
by Donald Trump in the book.
So we at that point speculated the total number.
You know, there's the 15 there's the 25 there
might be some overlap, maybe it's 35 women,
maybe it's 40 total women.
Considering that some of the women in the
book might already be known to us previously.
The book is now out as of two days ago and
it is endlessly more disgusting than we expected.
There are so many women who accused Donald
Trump of some form of molestation that the
book has a 50 page appendix containing a total
of about 200 women, 200 women making allegations
of molestation of different degrees against
the president of the United States.
The most interesting thing about it is that
Donald Trump's emo in most of these cases
is, uh, very similar.
Uh, but also he also seems to be the opposite
of a slick or a smooth operator.
Uh, according to what the women detail, it's
forcible kissing, which remember, Trump is
on tape saying when you're famous, you can
just kiss them.
You just kiss them, whatever.
Uh, it includes groping and genital grabbing.
Remember again in the tape, Trump says, grab
him by the, you know what?
So that is very much in line with what Donald
Trump has said he does before.
It includes setting up parties and events
where he can create situations of power dynamics
with specific women.
Very much in line to what he was known to
do with Jeffrey Epstein.
Even on video at a party in the, I believe
it was the late nineties just standing there
evaluating women with a very uncomfortable,
awkward looking, uh, Jeffrey Epstein, multiple
women who detail assaults taking place at
Donald Trump's Mar-a-Lago resort tell similar
stories of waking up and Trump is standing
in their bedroom.
I mean, can you imagine?
Many of the stories follow the trend that
when things aren't going well in one of Donald
Trump's marriages or relationships, the frequency
of these assaults increases and women are
targeted more frequently.
That's in line with everything we know, including
during rough patches in Donald Trump's relationship
with the now first lady, Melania Trump.
As we know, sometimes hush money is involved
to make stories go away.
Sometimes it's physical threats, threats of
violence, but in the end, is any of this going
to matter?
I mean, I'm not, I'm not telling you this
because now this is going to be what takes
down Trump.
The guy was elected after saying, you can
just grab them and do what you want.
Evangelical voters who supposedly vote their
values voted for Donald Trump after he said,
you just grab them wherever you want because
they don't actually care about the morality
that they claim to want to legislate, so what
difference is it going to make if it's 15
women or 40 women or 207 women or whatever
the number actually ends up being legally.
The statute of limitations on most of these
has expired legal repercussions.
Forget about it.
Unless there were recent payoffs, which could
be a campaign finance violations, depending
on how it was handled, there's not going to
be a single legal repercussion for this with
every single one of these violations of the
emoluments clause that Trump says is phony
with ignoring legal impeachment subpoenas
and Democrats not enforcing them.
None of this stuff is going to make a difference
unless, and 200 allegations of molestation
against women as well.
None of it will make a difference unless it
inspires people to go out and vote in November
of 2020 and I know it's almost a daily thing
that I'm saying right now.
If you think there could be other repercussions
from something like 200 plus women alleging
that Donald Trump molested them, let me know
what they are because I don't see it between
the statute of limitations between with all
of these other things, the fact that there
just have not been consequences to what Donald
Trump has done and continues to do.
I see every single one of these stories about
what Donald Trump has done, what Donald Trump
is accused of.
They are merely proxies to encourage voting
in November of 2020 which is only at this
point 53 53 and a half weeks away.
That is the most direct path to removing Trump.
And I know I've been saying this for a long
time, but do we think that there's going to
be something else in a short 53 and a half
weeks that will remove Trump as long as Republicans
continue to stand by him as long as um, uh,
Trump and his campaign officials and his administration
officials ignore congressional subpoenas with
no consequences, what is it that's going to
remove Trump any more quickly than just voting?
The guy out in 53 and a half weeks.
Let me know if you have a different view.
Let me know if you see a different path to
Trump's removal.
I'm on Twitter at the Pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show,
and remember, if you have Amazon prime, you
can subscribe free to you to my Twitch channel,
twitch.tv/david Pakman.
You subscribe with Twitch prime.
Okay.
If you have Amazon prime, you pay nothing.
It counts as a paid subscription for us.
A great way to funnel a little bit of that.
Jeff Bezos money into independent media twitch.tv/david
Pacman subscribed with Twitch prime.
We will take it [inaudible]
quick break and be back right after this,
the David Pakman show@davidpakmandotcom